the battle between Anne haitian's ex
James Tupper and her oldest son Homer
laffoon continues it's intense since
Anne's untimely death in August after a
fiery car crash her ex and her eldest
son started a war over her estate namely
who has control over her assets Homer no
he's a businessman he's gonna run my
business for me some days and now in new
court documents obtained by E.T James is
calling out the 20 year old claiming
Homer is hostile and has broken several
promises to his half-brother and James's
son with Ann Atlas according to James
Homer isn't giving his little brother a
list of their mom's belongings which
James says Atlas should have the chance
to look through before Homer decides
where the items end up I'm a dad that's
what dads do James further alleges Homer
has refused to communicate with Atlas or
his Representatives at all so how does
this affect Homer's latest request to
expand his authority as special
administrator of his mom's four hundred
thousand dollar estate well James argues
it shows the 20 year lack of competence
and inability to handle the job calling
the whole situation wasteful and
needless litigation but that's not all
he's also taken issue with Homer's
petition for an 800 000 probate bond
which James is countering should be set
at two million dollars as of now Homer's
currently overseeing and the state
[Music]